I
SO W THE ANSWER TO T
QUESTIONS.
O MUCH, WE TE IT, GOO TALK TO  G
GN TRA.
SAY BIDEN WON K
NOT,UN
RE AOW
TO BE CONSIDERED ALA Y'RE ILL>>D
RTN'ITHEOVS HAVE  AA OF ELECTIO
HO.ARY THAT VICTI A RUSSIAN
DO SOMEWHASE THE INFAMOU
DISCREDITED.OT JUST PRPIUSION.
ATLANTIC," OUR GUET  EVERYED BH
ASSESSED HE COUL
THAANT AT THE SENTENCE.
VINDU        AN US NOW.THESE TRT
.D THAT LEOME OFG PRESTIGIOUS PW
E M HEEW
JUYI USED TO
SC OFFEOT LIKE.
E YOU,EVS, THE.THEY DON'T LCS T
TO ATHEY DE EMNDOFT TRUM
REASONS,THR  TPECIFICALLY
T TO BTIC," IT.T ER AND LEAVE MU
N THE RELATIAWAY WK DAVID. Y
AND THIS INFORMATION ALLOM OM TN
THE SE INTELLINCTE WHARTERS H IE
INVESTIGATION, TBIOF DONALD
BEGAN WHEN OF HIDE
MAN NAMED GEORGE PT E STH ONDOO
OUR PARDER HERNMENT ABIMPORTANT
AUSTAN A THE FIVE  THALINCORWAR.
AN THE FBI
ON BUT THE'STH
GORNPAUL MANAFORT THERE AS WEL
JARED KUSHTHERTE
I R WAS,
ANANER.HINK ABOUT THIS -E
ERSON,F  BOOK,OS BOO
IS PBAPR.
S PROBABLY GOING
A COUNTRY WITH AN
ECY F  ERM E ERNEEXTREMICAN
ELECTION AGAINST THE PERSON
H FOREHES THEY
DO LITTLESPIONAGGS BUT  ME
,
WHHE QUESTION.
THEN YOU
ANCIALRELATISHUMTO.YBTHANSWER DE
THE ING, ONE PLACE
RECO LIKE WHERE YOU'N GOE IN TH
OKBY THE WAY, EVERE
BAD BOOUO HAD MICHAEL FLYNN,  SS
NT
COME BAC, D,NY
LAWY SEIV
>> THE THING SO G ABOUT THE FLYN
DE INVOLVED IN
T S OLD T HE WAS NOT PART OF TE
E SNTHG RUMP ING, YOU WOULD THI
SESSIONS, T
FIRSTO LIED T
COSS.
HE WT COMPROMISED IN ANY SO WHY
"C KNOW E' AN EP
IN TS OSETWET TR.
WE DON'T COLUMBO
SAYS, ATE ?Y,T I HAVE NIDEA
IT'S HARE TO THES HAOUIE TO
SE.
HO LEADEVIHYED TICE PREC.
FRIDAYHAN OMAR. SMAN LORENMc AK
W OUAKHO?
T STR
IN THE HOPES THAT SOME
LL
BEING SPEAKER OF THE
ERSTE WATHESVE NO CONGRESS. W EN
HESPEAKERSHIP.AND SHE ,  GNGO DT
AIDES SHE OU ARESHE ENFORC
CONTROL OVER YOUR CARTHY ITIN WA
INLIIEE KEE GEA MAJORIESWEIRDO